[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débats de
reportage de chroniques sur public scena
90 minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts au 40e
jour de la ripost aux attaques
terroristes du Hamas les soldats
israélien ont mené une attaque dans un
hôpital de Gaza ce responsable des
opérations humanitaires d'urgence des
nations un
mett en garde pour les risques des
civils nous n'avons pas de carburant
pour faire fonctionner l'hôpital les
bébés nouvellement nés n'ont pas de
couveuse certains sont déjà morts nous
ne pouvons pas les déplacer c'est trop
dangereux nous nous préoccupons des
patients d'un hôpital qui ne fonctionne
pas l'armée israélienne peut-elle mettre
le ramas hors d'état de nuire sans
s'attaquer aux hôpitaux de Gaza comment
Israël met aussi une guerre de
communication en diffusant le plus
possible les images des attaques
terroristes du 7 octobre on répond à ces
questions avec nos experts dans une
minute et puis pour notre second débat
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour je vous propose un zoom sur les
dangers des réseaux sociaux notamment
pour les plus jeunes 40 États américains
au porter plainte contre méta la maisonm
de Facebook et Instagram l'accusant de
mettre notamment en péril la santé des
jeunes filles peut-on contrôler les
contenus des géants d'Internet comment y
arriver àir que l'offre d'information
d'images de produits culturels est de
plus en plus plétorique réponse dans
trois qu4 d'heure mais d'abord donc les
détails de cette opération militaire
contre l'hôpital alchifa opération
ciblée selon les termes de l'État hébreu
Lina
bouerudi des tirs et des explosions
retentissent dans la nuit la poussière
s'infiltre dans le plus grand complexe
hospitalier de la bande de Gaza alchifa
est pris d'assaut par les soldats
israéliens vers 1h du matin des soins
médicaux interrompus en
hô prau etélectricité des chars encer
toujours
l'hôpital àintérieur sont pris au piège
une situation humanitaire critique que
dénonce l'Organisation des Nations Unies
d'un point de vue humanitaire nous nous
préoccupons du bien-être des patients de
cet hôpital je comprends que les
Israéliens cherchent à retrouver les
dirigeants du Hamas mais ce n'est pas
notre
problème stratégique auamas des tunnels
situés en dessous de l'hôpital auraient
été empruntés par les otages
israéliens une version soutenue par les
États-Unis les membres du Hamas et du
Djihad islamique exploitent donc un
centre de commandement et de contrôle
depuis l'hôpital alchifa dans la ville
de Gaza ils y entreposent des armes et
sont prêts à répondre à une opération
militaire israélienne contre
l'établissement affirme vouloir épargner
les civils les forces de défense
israélienne mèent une opération terr à
Gaza pour vaincre le Hamas et sauver nos
otages Israël est en guerre contre le
Hamas et non contre les civils de Gaza
en milieu de journée l'armée israélienne
a communiqué des images où des soldats
livrent du matériel médical devant
l'hôpital
alchifa aucune présence médiatique ni
organisation internationale n'aurait été
autorisé à accéder à l'enceinte de
l'hôpital un manque d'information en
provenance de Gaza qui risque de
s'accentuer faute de carburant suffisant
l'opérateur paltel annoncé pension de
tous les services de télécommunication
d'ici quelques heures à
Gaza pourquoi l'armée israélienne
a-t-elle pris cet hôpital pour cible
faut-il diffuser les images de l'attaque
terroriste du 7 octobre ce sont les deux
grands thèmes de notre débat avec Jérôme
clè bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
enseignant en prospective et stratégie à
science pour Paris et vous publiez la
prospective stratégique aux éditions
Herman Laurence sa bonsoir et bienvenue
ancienne correspondante en Israël et aux
États-Unis auteur de la newsletter sans
frontières qui paraît chaque jeudi
j'accueille également Antoine Basbous
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes fondateur
et directeur de l'Observatoire des pays
Arab auteur de ce livre le tsunami arabe
paru aux éditions faayard et Mathieu
croissandau bonsoir Mathieu
éditorialiste
politique dernières informations en
cette fin d'après-midi selon l'Agence
France Press qui cite un journaliste
collaborant avec avec l'agence l'armée
israélienne s'est retiré de cet hôpital
alchifa et s'est rep positionné on va
dire autour du site Jérôme clche
qu'est-ce qu'on sait de cette opération
opération militaire les soldats à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital qu'est-ce qu'on
en sait avec toute la prudence qui nous
caractérise parce que c'est difficile
d'avoir des informations fiables depuis
un terrain de guerreou naturellement
c'est une opération militaire donc
ciblée qui pourrait presque s'apparenter
à une opération de police armée dans le
sens où le complexe hospitalier en fait
a été complètement encerclé avec des
blindés donc vraiment aux portes de
l'hôpital des chars aux portes de l'
hôpital mais des troupes qui à
l'intérieur ont fait un travail de
discrimination important l'idée étant
pour elle de faire sortir c'était les
hommes de plus de 16 ans voilà et de les
faire sortir les mains euh non pas sur
la tête mais les mains en l'air de sorte
à pouvoir vraiment trier au cas par cas
et épargnant évidemment euh les civils
les patients le personnel médical
pouvoir remonter et puis les réfugiés
aussi certains réfugiés civils dans cet
hôpital pouvoir remonter en fait au
terroriste qui finalement ce serait ce
serait dissimulé dans cet hôpital jusque
dans les tunnels dont la question en
fait ne fait pas débat il y a des
tunnels effectivement sous sous cet
hôpital ils ont été construits bien
avant que Israël se retire de la bande
de Gaza en 2005 donc la question n'est
pas tant de savoir est-ce qu'il y a des
tunnels et est-ce qu'il sont utilisés à
des fins à des fin armé j'ose pas dire
militaire par le Hamas ça c'est
quasiment entendu la question c'est de
savoir et ça a été redit d'ailleurs par
le renseignement américain la question
c'est de savoir si cette opération là
telle qu'on l'a décrit peut suffire à
remplir les deux objectifs que sont un
la libération des otages de
l'éradication du Hamas oui et puis
est-ce que ça se fait ce selon le droit
international c'est aussi une une partie
du débat on en parlera évidemment
Laurent
Saim dernière info tiens le le le
président français à propos de de cette
opération à l'hôpital alchifa je je cite
l'agence franceoise Emmanuel Macron
condamne avec la plus grande fermeté les
bombardements d'infrastructurees civiles
c'est intérêt parce que toute cette
opération militaire israélienne elle est
aussi tenue par le regard de la
communauté internationale on l'évoquera
ensemble un peu plus tard mais je
voudrais vraiment rester sur le
l'objectif ou les objectifs de Tal de
l'armée israélienne est-ce qu'il est-ce
qu'ils ont pu imaginer qu'il y avait par
exemple beaucoup d'otagees dans les
sous-sols de cet hôpital ce qui aurait
justifié cette opération oui et c'est
pas hier qu'ils l'ont imaginé c'est
depuis de semaines qu'ils ne cesse de
dire quand vous écoutez les briefings
que Hamas
cache les otages les armes au milieu de
la population civile et notamment sous
des hôpitaux c'est pas hier qu'ils ont
disséminé à la presse aussi les plans
d'un hôpital très complexe qui est
extrêmement grand ils sont absolument
persuadés et ils le communiquent et
c'est très difficile pour nous
journaliste de le vérifier puisqu'on
n'est pas sur place il communique le
fait que ils ont raison d'aller dans cet
hôpital parce que en dessous de
l'hôpital ils sont absolument persuadés
et ils l'ont montré d'ailleurs dans des
vidéos qu'ils ont livré à la presse des
salles où il y aurait des installations
pour des otages on a vu un soldat
faisant comme un journaliste un plateau
dans le sous-sol de l'hôpital et
montrant un biberon qui était sur le mur
avec un accès direct à l'hôpital et
cetera après encore une fois ce qu'il
faut c'est des gens indépendants des
organisations humanitaires des
journalistes qui soient sur place pour
qu'on nit pas simplement le message
israélien qui dit on a raison d'aller
sous l'hôpital parce que c'est sous
l'hôpital que Hamas s'est caché c'est
sans doute des conflits c'est le plus
compliqué pour les journalistes d'aller
d'aller vérifier on va écouter tiens je
vous donne la parole juste après Antoine
les explications de la porte-parole de
l'armée israélienne sur cette
opération ces dernières semaines les
forces de défense israéliennes ont
averti publiquement à plusieurs reprises
que l'utilisation militaire permanente
du Hamas à l'hôpital Shifa mettait en
péril sa protection en vertu du droit
internationale danielar le porte-parole
évidemment de l'armée israélienne que
dit la Convention de Genève sur cette
question article 18 les hôpitaux civils
organisés pour donner des soins aux
blessés aux malades infirmes aux femmes
en couche ne pourront en aucune
circonstance être l'objet d'attaque ils
seront en tout temps respectés et
protégés par les partis au conflit
Antoine Basbous Israël peut-elle
combattre le ramas sans s'attaquer aux
hôpitaux et donc d'une certaine façon
violer cette convention de Genève si ce
soir l'armée israélienne avait montré
les otages récupérés vivants à l'hôpital
s'ils avaient montré la le QG du Hamas
dont ils ont dont ils parlent depuis des
semaines et bien tout le monde ce serait
incliné il aurait dit ah le
renseignement israélien est très
performant mais ce soir à l'heure o on
parle en cette fin d'après-midi à cette
heure-ci force est de constater que
l'échec du renseignement israélien s'est
établi encore aujourd'hui après le 7
octobre donc au nom de quoi on attaque
ont détruit on met hors service 23 de
des 35 hôpitaux à Gaza donc les autres
hôpitaux ne sont pas dans de meilleures
conditions puisque l'électricité n'est
plus là l'eau est extrêmement rare que
les médicaments manquent bref je laisse
les les dirigeants de l'ONU parler de
cela mais à vrai dire c'est c'est un
échec de renseignement israélien ça veut
dire que vous attendez des preuves de la
présence de d'hommes ou de quartiers
généraux du ramas dans les tunnels de
ces hôpitaux ça fait des jours que
l'armée
israélienne explique qu'il faut attaquer
cet hôpital le prendre pour délivrer des
otages qui sont au sous-sol et
démanteler le QG qui donne accès au
tunnel de Gaza ils auraient pu
d'ailleurs passer dans ces tunnels par
d'autres portes que parce que les
tunnels soi-disant se s'étendent sur 500
km ils ont plusieurs entrées et sorties
donc ils auraient pu vérifier cela sans
détruire l'hôpital passer par d'autres
voies d'autres voies d'accès et de
sortie dans ces tunnels mat pardon j'ai
une question un peu de béoien mais si ça
fait des jours que l'armée israélienne
le dit en effet qu'il a ce ce ce centre
de commandement du Hamas sous l'hôpital
et peut-être des otages ça fait
peut-être aussi des jours que Hamas a
démantelé son centre de commandement et
que les otages sont partis Israël était
censé le savoir puisque rien ne se fait
à Gaza sans la
connaissance use d'Israël pardon inter
votre avis làdessus peut-être allez
Laurent sa d'abord jérme cl juste après
non petite précision à ce que vous dites
il y a pas que les Israéliens qui disent
ça il y a la porteparole du Pentagone
qu'on vient d'entendre mais B les échecs
du renseignement américains on les a
connus il y a plusieurs années mais là
en tout cas les Américains et ça a été
confirmé par Joe Biden qui la nuit
dernière était en route vers San
Francisco pour rencontrer le président
et avec John Kirby qui était à bord Air
Force One les Américains ont assuré
qu'ils avaient des preuves
h alors vous parlez de la porte-pole
pardon pardon je vais juste apporter un
élément puis vous parlez de la
porte-parole adjointe du Pentagone
sabrineassing on l'écoute jeonne la
parole juste
après nous savons que le Hamas et le
Djihad islamique palestinien utilisent
certains hôpitaux de la bande de Gaza
notamment l'hôpital alchifa pour
dissimuler et soutenir leurs opération
militair et de tenir les
otages
ils ont des tunnels sous ces hôpitaux
les membres du Hamas et du dihad
islamique exploitent donc un centre de
commandement et de contrôle depuis
l'hôpital alchifa dans la ville de Gaza
ils y entreposent des armes et sont
prêts à répondre à une opération
militaire israélienne contre
l'établissement il est beaucoup de
question de confiance dans ce débat jérô
cl est-ce qu'on peut faire plus
confiance à la porte-parole adjointe en
l'occurrence du Pentagone que au
porte-parole de Tal de l'armé sans doute
un peu plus de fait mais en effet à
partir du moment où on est dans une
guerre il y a forcément un combat des
récits et tout doit être considéré comme
étant à priori faisant partie de la
guerre des récits pour garder l'adhésion
le fait que les États-Unis corroborent
ce que dit Israël du coup aurait
tendance à légitimer euh davantage
l'opération laquelle aussi n'est pas
totalement j'allais dire orthogonale au
droit international puisque le droit
international prévoit la question des
boucliers humains et prévoit que des
hôpitaux perdent leur statut protecteur
s'il il sont instrumentalisés ce qui ne
veut pas dire pour autant que les
victimes civiles doivent passer par
pertes et profits mais néanmoins il y a
une problématique mais mais quand quand
Israël parle d'opération ciblée c'est
quoi c'est une façon de dire on respecte
le droit de la guerre c'est ça c'est
aussi une façon de dire si vous regardez
que la jeis dire le caractère
relativement indiscriminé parfois des
frappes et qui font qu'il y a des des
comment des victimes collatérales est
plutôt plus faible à présent qui ne l'a
éta dans les premiers jours les
premières semaines consécutivement au
massacre c'estàdire qu'il y a quelques
il y a deux courpes qui se croisent
initialement derrière les massacre
l'émotion était telle que finalement
n'importe quelle frappe était un petit
peu cautionné et elles ont été
extrêmement dures et pour le coup
relativement moins indiscrimin
relativement moins pardon discriminé
aujourd'hui elles le sont discriminées
aujourd'hui on ne parle pas de frappe
aérienne qui aurait tapé dites au fur à
mesure interrom au fur et à mesure que
je je je je redis ça avec mes mots que
l'émotion internationale retombe après
le 7 octobre l'acceptabilité est moindre
voilà et donc et donc Israël est en
train j'entends votre argument de cibler
un peu plus ces opérations l très
rapidement moi je voudrais quand même
qu'on arrête aussi de dire d'être
hypocrite dans le langage pratiqué en
terme de communication militaire on
entend toujours les mêmes mots dommages
collatéraux opération derrière ça il y a
des hom ça il y a quand même des
populations civiles qui souffrent et il
faut encore et toujours le rappeler là
sur C C histoire d'hôpital c'est très
compliqué parce que c'est la première
fois qu'avec les réseaux sociaux à
l'heure de l'information continue et
cetera on a pas de journalistes encore
une fois présent sur le terrain des
images de propagande et il faut
s'imaginer que d'un point de vue
israélien c'est comme si après le
Bataclan on disait B vous savez les
terroristes qui ont attaqué le Bataclan
ils sont cachés sous l'hôpital
laréboisière on y va ou pas et ils ont
des otages c'est ça qui se passe côté
israélien dans la mentalité israélienne
et donc il y a un aspect émotionnel
qu'il faut aussi bien prendre en compte
avec des Israéliens qui disent nous on
est persuadé avec nos renseignements et
les américains ils ont quand même
beaucoup dans cette période sensible à
jouer qui disent la même chose on va
voir si sous un hôpital on retrouve pas
des otages Antoine Basbous est-ce que on
peut plus faire confiance à la
communication américaine dans ce dans ce
dossier je rose question la source de la
communication américaine la
communication reprend ce que le Mossad
et le shimbet disent aux Américains et
en confiance B vous avez la parole et
l'ut longement donc on va laisser
Antoine Basbous développer son son idée
vous pourrez répondre après et en
l'occurrence euh les Américains suivent
sur Gaza suivent Israël en revanche sur
le Liban les et sur laassis Jordanie les
Américains mettent en garde Israël sur
la S Jordanie ils sont vraiment ils sont
inquiets de voir une
révolte une nouvelle Intifada ce se
jouer et au Sud Liban ils ont ils ont
peur que le
hezbah attaque davantage Israël et
qu'Israël réplique comme le voudrait le
ministre de la Défense en revanche sur
Gaza je crois que le renseignement
israélien est censé être plus proche du
terrain parce qu'ils sont dedans et
c'est lui qui nourrit le renseignement
américain alors je suis en désaccord
profond sur cette idée que le
renseignement israélien est nourri par
le renseignement
américain ENF le renseignement américain
est nourri par le renseignement donc je
suis en désaccord profond avec cette
idée ouré les Américains ont totalement
leur propres sources il y a des pavions
qui ont été envoyé avec des équipes de
renseignement qui sont sur place et il a
été confirmé par exemple que la team six
qui est une unité extrêmement
spécialisée dans l'armée américaine de
force spécial mais aussi d'agents de
renseignement est déjà sur place après
les massacres du 7 octobre les
Américains n'écoutent pas les Israéliens
et viennent pas au Pentagone faire un
communiqué pour dire ah ben tenez on est
sûr que ça il vérifie avant de faire ça
parce que l'enu est énorme je rappelle
aussi que les Américains ont des otages
ils ont beaucoup d'otages les Américains
on ne connaît pas le nombre précis donc
ils ont aussi indépendamment des
Israéliens des services de renseignement
sur place pour avoir des informations
sur combien il y a d' Tage qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire pour les sortir parce
que pour Biden c'est aussi une priorité
dans une période très sensible pour lui
mais est ce que dit Antoine basbou c'est
quand même intéressant sur le fait que
finalement cette communication
américaine g elle est elle est modulée
c'estàd que c'est pas la même quand on
parle de Gaza ou quand on parle de de la
S Jordanie par exemple que pour
l'instant pour l'instant la question
c'est celle de de Gaza la S Jordanie est
un tout autre problème évidemment lié
qu'on pourrait aborder mais en
l'occurrence il est pas est-ce que le
soutien américain il est unidimensionnel
et et de toute façon àquis à Israël
c'est c'est ça ce qui a derrière la
question end ben non on a entendu ces
derniers jours ces dernières semaines et
même encore aujourd'hui justement toutes
les réserves qu'émettaient les
États-Unis à chaque opération ou euh ou
disons phase d'opération lancé par
Israël si aujourd'hui j'allais dire
Israël en est là où elle en est sur le
plan de l'opération terrestre c'est
aussi parce que les Américains et
d'autres ont fait pression pour éviter
l'occupation pourer l'invasion et puis
effectivement de l'incursion on est
arrivé à une phase hybride qui ressemble
qui pourrait aller à un début
d'occupation de fait mais qui reste
encore extrêmement regardé y compris par
les États-Unis qui la semaine dernière
lorsque benamini et tianahou a dit nous
assumerons notre part de sécurité sur la
bande de Gaza a immédiatement traduit en
terme d'occupation et s levé contre ça
pour dire nous y sommes opposés donc non
il y a pas un blancin pour Israël je
crois que c'est assez clair là-dessus la
conclusion c'est que l'un et l'autre
pays se sont euh on rencontré l'échec
sur cette affaire de de l'hôpital
alchifa puisque tous les deux disêre un
peu tôt je je je bien être prudent à C
HECI à ch-ci selon nos informations il
est 18h19 à Paris à 7ette he-ci selon
nos informations il y a eu échec de
renseignement et américains et Isra
pourquo parce qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé
d'otage ou de terroristes du R ça je ne
sais pas pourquoie un
dire je me permet de dire deux choses
factuellement c'est encore un peu tôt
puisque pour le moment les Israéliens
disent on s retirait mais on est
toujours autour de l'hôpital donc on va
voir ce qui se passe deuxièmement les
Américains en ce moment pour revenir à
l'idée qui venait d'être développé il
tempèent les Israéliens ils ont peur
d'un embrasement général dans la région
et d'une certaine manière si
l'embrasement ne s'est pas passé et dans
une perspective historique quand il y
aura les débriefings de toutes les
réunions qui ont lieu entre les membres
du cabinet Biden qui au lendemain des
massacres du 7 octobre sont allés
physiquement en Israël ont rencontré les
membres du cabinet israélien quand on
saura vraiment ce qui s'est passé dans
cette réunion on verra peut-être que les
Américains on dit aux Israéliens
attention ne faites pas ça attention on
va vous soutenir pour le moment mais
évitons un embrasement général de la
région parce que n'oublions pas que au
lendemain des massacres du 7 octobre
c'était très compliqué de faire de
parler aux israéliens dans le degré
évidemment justifié d'émotion dans
lequel ils étaient et et je rappelle
j'ai déjà donné cette information la
prise de de parole du président français
manuel Macron qui condamne avec la plus
grande fermeté des bombardements
d'infrastructures civil est-ce qu'on
peut dire Jérôme clèche que cette
opération militaire à Gaza pas seulement
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui à
l'hôpital d'une manière générale c'est
une sorte de de contre la montre pour
Israël vous l'avez un peu évoqué tout à
l'heure mais Israël qui sait que le
soutien international ou en tout cas le
soutien occidental s frite alors c'est
un contre la montre c'est vrai parce
qu'effectivement le soutien comme vous
le dites la la bataille des opinions
publiques se perd petit à petit et et en
même temps benamin ytianou a clairement
annoncé qu'il s'agissait d'une guerre
longue ile et qu'il souhaite
probablement longue et difficile parce
qu'il y a deux aspects il y a l'aspect
stratégique et opérationnel au regard
des objectifs poursuivis et j'y
reviendrait donc la libération des
otages et l'éradication du Hamas et puis
il y a quand même un objectif politique
le concernant c'est quand même faire en
sorte un moment que dans l'intervalle de
traitement du problème la situation se
retourne à son avantage car si nous
devions faire le bilan aujourd'hui pour
lui ça signifierait sans doute une
sortie politique compte tenu des
enquêtes consécutives aux insuffisances
du 7 octobre mais je reviens sur les
objectifs là on je pense qu'on se
focalise à tort sur la question de
savoir si euh alchifa enferme ou pas
dans ces tunnel les raisons et des
motifs suffisants pour en faire un
objectif parmi d'autres mais un objectif
majeur sur le plan tactique et
stratégique c'est pas la question en
réalité oui effectivement c'est un
objectif et oui effectivement il y a des
terroristes qui se nichent sous ce sous
cet hôpital c'est pas vraiment le sujet
il y a tout un faisceau d'indice et là
l'appréciation autonome de situation
avec tous les capteurs dont dispos les
États-Unis ne fait pas de débat la vraie
question c'est de savoir si ça a une
chance de faire aboutir l'opération et
si ça peut conduire à libérer des otages
et à éédiquer le Hamas et là c'est quand
même le point majeur par l'extraction
directe pour l'instant non mais c'est un
peu tôt effectivement pour voir mais
c'est surtout par la pression imprimée
que ça peut permettre de diminuer le
prix pardon des négociations qui
aujourd'hui bégille àchope on en est
déjà la 3è 4 tenttive c'est ça le vrai
sujet c'est faire en sorte qu'Israël
accepte le prix demandé par le amas ou
l'inverse ouis pour libérer un certain
nombre d'otage il
avait 70 otages contre 5 jours de cesser
le feu allez on a on a assez longuement
mais c'était passionnant essayer de
comprendre ce qui s'était passé
aujourd'hui autour de cette à
l'intérieur et autour de cet hôpital je
vrais qu'on parle maintenant de la la
question des des images la diffusion des
des images des atrocités du du ramass le
7 octobre faut-il montrer ou non ces
images à qui à quoi ça peut servir je
propose à Jonathan du PRI de nous
rejoindre tout de suite bonsoir Jonathan
bienvenue à vous les les les députés ont
visionné un film qui retrace les
atrocités du du 7 octobre hier à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus ouais tout à
fait les députés hier Thomas ils ont
visionné un film d'une extrême violence
47 minutes d'un montage confectionné par
les autorités israéliennes qui montrent
de manière très crue et vous voyez
certaines de ces images sont issues de
ce ce film euh les les massacres
perpétrés par le Hamas qui ont fait 1200
morts côté israélien le 7 octobre
dernier euh ces images elles proviennent
de sources diverses multiples que ce
soit des caméras de vidéosurveillance
des portables aussi des victimes euh des
caméras des bourreaux eux-mêmes euh et
sans filtre voilà on on suit en fait le
récit de de cette journée terrible pour
Israël donc hier plusieurs dizaines de
députés ont assister à une séance qui se
tenait à huit clos à l'Assemblée
nationale mais certains comme le député
LR du lot Aurélien Pradier et bien ils
ont refusé de s'y rendre lui il voyait
en tout cas une une initiative
contre-productive et je vous propose de
l'écouter je suis un responsable
politique je connais mes forces et je
connais aussi mes faiblesses humaines et
je sais que si je participe à cette
projection là je ressortirai avec un
seul sentiment celui de la vengeance or
si nous installons dans notre pays comme
dans le monde comme seul guide politique
la vengeance alors nous ne réussirons
rien mais surtout les organisations
gagneront et donc Thomas le Sénat
organise une sé mêmetiv ou le Sénat
voilà envoie le pas à l'Assemblée
nationale et ti se tiendra ici au Palais
du Luxembourg mardi à 19h une séance un
tout petit peu différente le film sera
cette fois de 50 minutes rallongé avec
des sous-titres ce qui n'était pas le
cas à l'Assemblée nationale et et les
sénateurs et sénatrices en ce moment
même se pose aussi la question de de
visionner ou pas ces images on peut dire
qu'Israël joue en quelque sorte sa sa
partie
on est dans cette logique de de
communication et de guerre
informationnelle c'est ça et tout
conflit suppose cette guerre
informationnelle entre les belligérants
et ce conflit évidemment ne fait pas
exception pour les journalistes couvrir
ce qui se passe dans la banque de Gaza
et je vous entendais l'aborder dans la
première partie et ben c'est un immense
défi parce qu'on est on est obligé de se
se baser sur des sources qui émanent de
ces deux camps et donc le Hamas qui est
une organisation terroriste diffuse des
images de propagande via un seul réseau
téégram et côté israélien et bien c'est
un peu l'inverse c'est une machine
extrêmement rodé tout ce qui sort de
Gaza est contrôlé par l'armée euh ce
sont des images des prises de parole
degadé extrêmement millimétré hein c'est
une communication qui est aussi relée
massivement sur les réseaux sociaux et
notamment le compte du de l'armée 2005
de d'abonnés sur sur X euh et en dehors
de ces canaux bah c'est un peu le
brouillard de la guerre reporter sans
frontière parle de blackout médiatique à
Gaza et l'accès aux journalistes sur ce
territoire est toujours interdit hein
par Israël et par l'Égypte seul quelques
journalistes Palestiniens qui sont
bloqués à Gaza continuent d'informer
dans des conditions extrêmes écoutez à
ce sujet un des responsables de la FP
qui parlait au Sénat ailleurs dans le
passé c'était toujours possible de
mettre des des renforts à Gaza pour pour
des autres conflits guerres et cetera
cette fois-ci c'est pas possible c'est
extrêmement difficile nos journalistes
travaillent dans des situations très
très ils sont dans une précarité extrême
on a évacué notre bureau à Gaza City
parce que c'est c'est é dans la zone où
les Israéliens nous a demandé tout le
monde de de de fuir on a évacué notre
bureau il y a des jours de
semaines je pense c'est bien connu que
notre bureau a souffert un
frappe il y a une semaine il y avait
personne dedans mais les les dommages
sur le bâtiment sont sont considérables
voilà Thomas et ces journalistes
présents à Gaza ils ont payé un lourd
tribut à la converture de de ce conflit
lors de la semaine qui a suivi l'attaque
du 7 octobre et bien il y a h
journalistes qui ont été tués dans
l'exercice
de leur métier la plupart sinon tous
sous les bombardements israéliens
l'affirme l'ONG reporter sans
frontièrees merci beaucoup Jonathan pour
pour toutes ces informations Mathieu je
me tourne vers vous est-ce qu'il faut
aller encore plus loin montrer ces
images au grand public c'est une
question difficile qui se pose à travers
l'histoire depuis qu'il y a des images
de massacre est-ce que ne pas montrer
les images de massacre c'est nier le
massacre ou est-ce que montrer les
images du massacre c'est massacré de foi
alors il faut bien sûr que ces images
existent qu'elles aent été vues qu'elles
soient raconté qu'elles soi eré pour
l'histoire peut-être un jour même que
certaines d'entre elles soient
sélectionnées contextualisé dans un
documentaire à voocation mémoriel
journalistique mais la diffusion à mes
yeux d'images brutes de massacre au
grand public à une époque où celle-ci
peuvent être instrumentalisé détourné
trafiqué ça me paraît plutôt inhumain et
dangereux d'abord par respect pour les
victimes ça serait prendre le risque
d'ajouter de l'indignité à la barbarie
tout n'est pas montrable au sens où tout
ne doit pas forcément être montré tout
le temps à tout le monde de la société
de la transparence doit pas devenir une
société de l'indescendance est-ce que
pour autant le gouvernement israélien a
eu tort de dé montrer al on comprend
bien pourquoi il l'a fait et j'observe
qu'il l'a fait à travers un filtre
c'està-dire en réservant la diffusion à
des journalistes ou à parce que c'est
leur métier ou à des personnes qui
voulaient en faire le témoignage le
problème c'est que ce filtre aujourd'hui
a perdu en crédibilité le discrédit qui
frappe toute parole officielle celle des
politiques et toute parole
professionnelle celle des journalistes
ben ça rend les choses beaucoup plus
complexes dans une époque où dire les
fait ne suffit plus ce qui revient à
poser une question intéressante mais
aussi très complexe faut-il voir pour
croire alors on a encore eu un exemple
hier je fais une parenthèse ça n'a rien
à voir mais avec cet imam de la Grande
Mosquée de Paris qui s'étonnait par
exemple de ne pas avoir vu des
agressions de Juifs à la télévision
semblant remettre en cause la réalité
statistique de la flambée antisémite ça
pourrait plaider pour tout montrer mais
qu'on ne s trompe pas je pense qu'à
l'heure de la vérité alternative et du
complottisme beaucoup de ceux qui
réclament de voir pour y croire n'y
croiront pas même après avoir vu il s'en
trouvera toujours pour disséquer les
images suspecter des mises en scène des
comédiens on a déjà vu ça plusieurs fois
par le passé mais c'est certitude c'est
qu'on ne restaurera pas la confiance
dans journalisme en niant le métier de
journaliste c'estàdire en diffusant des
images brutes sans les avoir vérifié
recoupé sélectionné ni mise en
perspective merci Mathieu je sur ce
thème je vous donne évidemment la parole
à tous les trois mais j'accueille
Christian Delage qui est historien
auteur de filmer juge de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale à l'invasion de
l'Ukraine en édition de poche et folio
vous avez signé une tribune bonsoir vous
avez signé une tribune sur ce thème hier
dans le monde c'est pour ça qu'on a
souhaité vousouvoir participer à notre
débat à propos de la diffusion de ces
images au au au députés français est-ce
que vous êtes gêné par la diffusion de
ces images et si oui pourquoi bah la
première question c'est de savoir
pourquoi on on montre ces images au
députés pourquoi on les montre à la
presse c'est parfaitement compréhensible
parce que elle ne les a pas vu dans leur
grande majorité mais les députés est-ce
qu'il y a eu un débat après est-ce qu'il
y a eu une réflexion qui s'est nouée
autour de ce film est-ce queil y a une
matière documentaire qui va être
réutilisé c'est ça la question quand je
regarde les réactions et c'est ce que
j'avais anticipé dans ma tribune je je
dirais ce film ne va provoquer que de
laassidération et bien j'observe en
lisant libération ce matin que euh
le président du groupe Renaissance dit
que c'était des séquences très dures des
séquences insupportables Jérôme gage son
collège socialisie c'était des images
d'effroid c'était silencieux à la
hauteur de la sidération le terme que
j'ai employé précisément dans ma tribune
donc je me dis est-ce que les députés
avaient besoin de voir des images de ces
massacres pour quoi pour croire en leur
vérité donc si on passe au niveau de il
s'agit effectivement de donner une
vérité alors là il y a un certain nombre
de précautions qu'il faut prendre qui
n'ont pas été prises les images que
vousation pardon vous interrompre de
contextualisation d'abord protection les
images que vous avez montré tout à
l'heure de de ces militants du Hamas
dans les pickup arrivant donc dans le
kibbots ces images nous les avons déjà
vu nous les avons vu à la télévision et
ces images ont été floutées sil y a des
victimes et très souvent s'arrête au
moment de la Commission du crime or les
images qui ont été montrées dans ce
montage diffusé devant les députés il
n'y a pas de foutage et on voit la
Commission du crime 50 % de ces images
ont été faites par les militants du
Hamas par des caméras porté sur leur
corps donc nous sommes dans l'axe de
vision des criminels je je je je demande
qui peut peut supporter de telles images
et est-ce qu'on peut se mettre dans
cette position là en tant que spectateur
Laurent Saï vous aviez fait partie des
premiers journalistes internationaux à
avoir convi d'ailleurs par l'armée
israélienne à visionner ces images vous
étiez venu en parler ici même le le le
c'était l'après-midi même euh vous
pensez qu'elle doit être montré ces
images pourquoi quand on parle dejwitz
il faut voir les images ou se dire ah
c'est trop dur 6 millions de personnes
sont mortes je ne peux pas voir moi je
ne pense pas qu'on doit dire il faut ou
il ne faut pas il y a un fait historique
qui a déclenché une guerre les massacres
du 7 octobre ont déclenché une guerre il
y a effectivement le Hamas qui a filmer
il y a pas de commentaires sur les
images qui ont
été projeté aux journalistes et je suis
pour tout montrer et je pense qu'à
l'époque grand absolument parce que je
pense que le grand public on ne doit pas
penser pour le grand public c'est au
grand public de décider et les gens sont
beaucoup plus intelligent qu'on le pense
c'est comme quand on dit comment on fait
de l'audience ah les gens ne vont pas
regarder non c'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe les gens ils ont la possibilité
et la liberté de décider s'ils veulent
regarder quelque chose qui a été filmé
par plusieurs caméras les caméras du
Hamas les caméras de surveillance dans
les maisons les caméras de surveillance
dans les voitur dit Mathieu moi je suis
assez d'accord avec Mathieu pardon vous
interrompe c'est que c'est notre travail
c'est quand même de de trier de filtrer
de choisir et peut-être de ne pas tout
montrer justement mais moi je pense qu'à
l'époque des réseaux sociaux on ne peut
plus faire ce travail comme on le
faisait il y a 10 ans c'est-à-dire que
d'abord dans la majorité des images de
ce film la majorité de ces images elles
ont déjà été mises sur les réseaux
sociaux les gens qui ont envie de voir
ces images il y en a beaucoup il y a
beaucoup de gens qui les ont vu et je
pense qu'on ne doit pas nous dire il
faut ou il faut pas c'est un document
qui déclenche une crise
internationale avec des conséquences
peut-être qu'on ne soupçonne pas et bien
c'est le point de départ de cette crise
qu'il faut regarder et après on peut
organiser des débats et les gens qui se
disent choqués ah non je ne supporterais
pas c'est trop dur et cetera moi je n'y
crois pas je pense que c'est une fausse
excuse lorsque vous avez une
responsabilité médiatique politique
politique ou un devoir avant de parler
avec votre responsabilité de ce conflit
de voir les faits et ce qui s'est passé
le 7 octobre ce sont des faits bon
Antoine basb V ravis moi je n'ai pas vu
le film volontairement vous auriez pu le
voir je n'ai pas été invité à le voir
mais bon je sais pas je serais allé
regarder ce film mais exhiber des crimes
devant l'Assemblée nationale devant les
les parlementaires à chaud comme ça sans
hauteur sans distance sans discernement
c'est c'est de la précipitation et le
fait ça fait 40 jours je je on est on
est on est dans la guerre la guerre à 40
jours mais elle n'est pas terminée et
donc si on est dans la précipitation
peut-être qu'on est aussi dans la
justification de la vengeance qui a
suivi donc c'est ça qui me
chiffonne j'aimerais bien voir ce film
oui c'est ça doit être on on n'est pas
DUP de l'objectif qui est euh poursuivi
par par l'État d'Israël enoui estce que
l'assemblée est obligée de suivre les
désirs de de tsal et de l'État d'Israël
ils peuvent avoir un peu de distance
mais moi j'ai pas vu le film et je
j'imagine ce que ça être comme crime euh
extrêmement violent euh Jérôme clè votre
avis là-dessus on l'a un peu évoqué tout
à l'heure on revient à cet argument de
de voilà de de du du contre la montre
c'est un peu tri de dire ça mais c'est
la réalité c'est ça moi je m'exprimerais
j'allais dire sur sur ce planlà il
m'appartient pas de juger de savoir s'il
fallait produire ses images ou pas en
revanche avoir une idée sur si cette
stratégie cette dimension
informationnelle parce qu'on en est
encore là de la stratégie à un sens
l'idée générale évidemment c'est de
reéhausser le curseur émotion euh et
faire en sorte qu'il prennent le pas sur
le curseur raison d'une certaine manière
et faire en sorte que la légitimité dont
bénéficiait Israël au premers jour des
massacres soit ravivé finalement dans
son acuité c'est ça l'enjeu et de
permettre finalement à Israël d'opérer
comme elle opère actuellement pour
encore finalement quelques jours
quelques semaines peut-être quelques
mois sans qu'elle ne soit entravée
autrement que par des exhortations et
des condamnations c'est bien ça l'enjeu
là je dirais que ça aura un effet euh
utile pour pour comment les objectifs
poursuivis si toutefois la pression
militaire qui est imprimée permet
d'arriver à des négociations pour la
libération des otages en revanche pour
l'éradication du Hamas ou pour sortir de
cette mécanique du chaos dans laquelle
Israël est deux faites engagé et c'était
le piège du Hamas et elle ne pouvait pas
finalement c'est là où le Hamas a toute
sa part de responsabilité y compris sur
les victimes civiles collatérales c'est
que Israël ne pouvait pas ne pas engager
cette dynamique du chaos et il le savait
bien et bien ça effectivement j'allais
dire c'est pas quelques semaines de
gagner au regard d'une émotion qui
serait un peu ravivé dans sa force qui
permettra de sortir du problème
Christian Delage vous évoquiez
précisément le le le dans dans votre
première intervention le fait de montrer
ces images à à des parlementaires
français je rappelle que elles seront
montrées également au sénateur la la la
semaine prochaine là on évoque plus la
question du du grand public euh
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez le risque
c'est quoi c'est que l'émotion attise le
cercle de de la haine ou de la
vengeance d'après mes informations enfin
je veux dire d'après ce que j'ai lu dans
la presse euh le gouvernement israélien
aimerait bien montrer ce film ou des
extraits de ce film à un plus grand
public que celui des des des assemblées
puisqu'il a été aussi montré à
laacnesset hein euh simplement les
familles des victimes ne le veulent pas
les familles des victimes ne veulent pas
qu'on voit leur leurs parents euh
assassiner je je je donne l'exemple dans
ma tribune de de ces images qui figurent
donc dans ce film où un un un père de
famille est avec ses deux enfants à
l'intérieur de son foyer une grenade est
lancée par un militant du Hamas le père
décède devant ses enfants et l'un des
enfants enfant perd un œil et qui a
envie de voir ces images là excusez-moi
mais enfin je veux dire c'est quand même
des choses terribles alors il ne s'agit
pas de il faut séparer si vous voulez ce
qui est l'attestation d'un crime et ça
c'est évidemment très important quel que
soit le crime qu'il y ait une
attestation et ça passe aussi par des
images et elle pourra être utile pour
l'histoire ou pour un procès éventuel
notamment alors si vous voulez quand on
parle de procès ça veut dire qu'il y a
justement là une médiation qui s'opère
hein les images sont montrées dans dans
un certain cadre avec un environnement
de présentation une mise en perspective
tout ce qui à mon sens ne figure pas
dans ce dans ce montage qui d'ailleurs
évolue tout le temps on en est à la 11e
version euh donc ça ça ça au fond
certaines images nont été montré par
exemple que sous forme photographique
c'est tout ce qui concerne les les bébés
euh mais en revanche les images animées
concernant les meurtres de bébés ont été
montrés à Monsieur blinken le secrétaire
d'État américain dans une projection
privée donc je je crois qu'il y a soit
si vous voulez on produit un montage qui
possède un commentaire qui met en
perspective ce que les Américains ont
fait et les Soviétiques de leur côté en
1945 avant même que le procès de nurber
et lieu au mois de juin un film avait
été fait à la demande du président eener
donc certes c'était une demande
officielle mais parce que eener avait
été sur les lieux avait été extrêmement
choqué et avait dit pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de négation il faut que des images
soient prises et qu'elles soient
montrées la différence quand même je je
le redis c'est que aujourd'hui on prête
beaucoup d'importance à la protection de
l'intimité des individus c'est une
question éthique qu'il faut respectter
et les familles ne veulent pas qu'on
voit alors justement sur ce point précis
Laurence vouliez réagir oui moi je
voulais réagir parce que je crois qu'il
y a une différence culturelle et je
pense que les Israéliens dans souvent le
deuil ont une réaction similaire aux
Américains qui est très différente de ce
qui se passe en France et on couvert
beaucoup de drames aux États-Unis j'ai
toujours été très étonné quand un père
perd sa fille le lendemain on le voit
sur toutes les chaînes de télévision il
a la photo de sa fille sur sa poitrine
et il dit voilà j'ai perdu ma fille et
je veux toujours qu'elle existe les
Israéliens ils veulent que le monde voit
ça ne vous y trompez pas des familles
qui ont demandé à ce que les images so
pas diff en tout cas la majorité des
Israéliens lorsque vous les interrogez
et j'ai parlé à de nombreuses personnees
sur ce thème très sensible ils veulent
que le monde voit ça ils disent vous
allez comprendre notre colère vous allez
comprendre ce qui se passe vous devez
voir ça pour comprendre le début de
cette guerre et donc parler pour eux et
dire non les familles de victimes et
cetera moi je ne crois pas à ça dans la
majorité de la population israélienne
juste Laurence les faits ils ont été
documentés ils ont été attestés ils ont
été racontés les scènes elles ont été
décrites qu'est-ce que ça change l'image
ça change de voir les choses telles
qu'elles se sont passées et je ne suis
pas là et je ne veux pas me dire il faut
ou il ne faut pas il y a un document qui
existe qui a été fait avec plusieurs
points de vue les caméras de
surveillance encore une fois à
l'intérieur des maisons israéliennes de
sécurité qui est une caméra extrêmement
neutre he c'est une caméra qui est
accrochée sur un mur pour voir si
quelqu'un pénètre dans le salon les
caméras qui sont fixées au corps des
terroristes du Hamas qui sont l'autre
angle qui a été fait pour de manière
assez neutre dans le montage quand vous
êtes un professionnel et que vous voyez
la manière dont ce montage a été fait
vous avez souvent une double fenêtre
avec la caméra du terroriste et de
l'autre la caméra de surveillance collée
au mur qui montre la scène après ce sont
des scènes de massacre mais encore une
fois par exemple cette semaine j'étais
dans plusieurs villages de France il y a
beaucoup de gens qui me disent c'est pas
possible ça pas existé le 7 octobre vous
exagérez c'est pas possible on y croit
pas B moi je me dis que à un moment
donné le public pourrait croire il a
peut-être besoin de voir ça et les gens
qui sont trop sensibles ne le verront
pas un dernier mot là-dessus le le débat
est quasiment terminé Antoine est-ce
qu'il faut les réserver à à
effectivement un procès pour l'histoire
C je crois que montrer ça à chose c'est
pas forcément c'est de la précipitation
c'est faire plaisir à ceux qui les ont
produites c'est participer à un climat
de crispation Éton parce que faire
plaisir à ceux qui les ont produit ce
sont les teroristes enfin pour partie ce
sont les thoristes duamas qui les on qui
ont préparé le documentaire donc le
documentaire a un objectif l'objectif
c'est de d'avoir carte blanche pour la
pour pour comment
dirais-je la revanche en quelque
sorte la vengance oui mais bon est-ce
qu'on doit voir ça à chaud je je je suis
pas sûr est-ce que ça doit être présenté
au Sénat et à l'Assemblée je suis pas
certain mais il y avait aussi un
objectif du ramas Jérôme clèche puisque
il tournait ses images ils avaient ils
avaient pas ses caméras sur eux par
hasard naturellement l'objectif premier
c'était on l'évoquait justement de de
créer un piège h et de faire en sorte
que la réaction soit lu comme étant
disproportionnelle estelleelle pas on va
pas revenir sur ce débatl voilà mais de
toute façon de créer une réaction
israélienne qui serait telle que ça
engagerait Israël dans un mécanisme du
chaos qui n'est pas propre à Israël que
ça a été le cas pour la lutte contre
l'État islamique où Mossou et raka ont
été véritablement rasés c'est ça a été
le cas aussi dans une autre mesure en
Afghanistan c'est le cas dès lors qu'on
est engagé quand dans une lutte contre
la terreur d'une certaine manière et
c'était le cas aussi je parle sous le
contrôle de de l'historien qui est en
ligne pendant le débarquement en
Normandie où il y a eu des victimes
collatérales civiles donc si vous voulez
l'idée de de faire peser finalement la
responsabilité à la partie d'en face en
le poussant dans ces retranchement c'est
quelque chose effectivement dont dont on
procède tout dernier mot dernier mot on
est dans une nouvelle époque la
communication de la terreur notre
génération on sait pas comment la gérer
et donc il va falloir apprendre à la
gérer parce que là on est dans un débat
sur les massacres du 7 octobre on peut
aussi rapidement dans les jours
prochains sur un débat sur qu'est-ce qui
se passe quand un otage va être exécuté
devant une caméra et il va falloir le
gérer et cette communication de terreur
qui est pratiqué en ce moment par des
mouvements terroristes de manière
globale il faut que les médias les
politiques et l'opinion publique
prennent leur responsabilité pour gérer
cette communication de terreur qui fait
partie des nouvelles guerres auxquelles
nous sommes confrontés merci beaucoup et
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on en a fait
évidemment un chapitre assez large de ce
débat merci à à tous d'y avoir participé
je vais RA rappeler les titres euh de
vos livres Jérôme clèch la prospective
stratégique c'est aux éditions Herman
Antoine Basbous le tsunami arabe publié
chez Fayard euh Christian delâ merci
également d'avoir participé à notre
émission filmé juger c'est chez Folio en
édition poche et puis il y a votre
newslet Laurence sa motage sans
frontièrees qui paraît deincé chaque
jeudi je vous dis à bientôt sur sur
Public Sénat